see if I can catch them take them
no no this fan you can adjust with the
Atlanta lens is not sticking straight
out much just just it's okay
yeah I'm just trying to get your walking
down straight down this walkway just
nuts up what's the height is done after
this the amount of but the ban just they
could have that way
yeah
hey Betsy
it's Kaitlyn Kaitlyn on her way up
so watch it won't sit Center shoot got a
little sliver that's for the last time I
think you're standing where you're
supposed to go
I think I like it are you wondering
since I
I think so
right
I believe we're probably going to be
getting Camuto right out of this dial-in
all right duck we're gonna go this time
I don't go mask is missing you just took
a picture of yourself with
so it transitions to the its have access
to the best of devices with Asia when
you're wearing a basement
they don't a year ago I took me for
getting an update through your phones
good afternoon everyone I'd like to
begin by detailing the historic private
public partnership effort launched by
the Trump administration to combat the
corona virus as both a businessman and
as president you'll all remember then
candidate Donald Trump now President
Donald Trump being adamant about
bringing manufacturing jobs back to
America President Obama and the
Democrats had given up on manufacturing
with President Obama's erroneously
prediction that Trump would need a magic
wand in order to bring back American
jobs not so the reality is president
Trump revived manufacturing in this
country and he tore up disastrous trade
deals that hemorrhaged American jobs
like NAFTA and like the plan that was in
work the trans-pacific partnership
instead he put in place better trade
deals to bring back American jobs and to
bring back American manufacturing and in
the battle against the invisible enemy
President Trump took action to shore up
our domestic supply chains in order to
deliver the necessary PPE and other
medical equipment to the state's speaker
Pelosi and House Democrats are currently
promoting a three trillion dollar
liberal which lists among a litany of
Democrat priorities and material to the
coronavirus crisis are embedded in this
and one would require the President to
appoint a quote medical supplies
response coordinator who would quote
serve as the point of contact for the
health care system supply chain
officials and the states on medical
supplies I'm happy to report this
individual already exists this bill
ignores reality because the medical
supplies official is in existence he's
been working on this since March to
deliver to date over billions and
billions in 1 billion I should say
pieces of PPE two countries and
hospitals across the country since March
29th Rear Admiral John Plouffe Czech
vice director for logistics for the
Joint Chiefs has been on the job as the
head of FEMA supply chain stabilization
task force this is a historic
partnership with the private sector and
under the leadership of President Trump
FEMA directed the greatest mobilization
of the private sector since World War
two Rear Admiral of check and FEMA
quickly realized the power of the
private sector and addressing the
coronavirus
recognising that the six largest private
sector medical distributors would have
the ability to source procure
manufacture and deliver as many as 1
billion pieces of PPE in a single week
that is extraordinary volume by our
private sector and at the direction of
President Trump we're at Rear Admiral of
check and FEMA were able to harness this
power every day at 9:00 a.m. Rear
Admiral pull-up checks team Huddle's
with the six large private sector
medical distributors and together they
review data compiled by dr. Burks as
well as information provided by the CDC
to set priorities and ensure sufficient
levels of supplies go down not just to
the county level but to the hospital
level after focusing geographically Rear
Admiral club Chuck and his team Orient's
the data to set point-of-care
distribution priorities for public
hospitals VA and DOD facilities private
hospitals nursing homes acute click
excuse me acute care clinics first
responders and labs in just two and a
half weeks Rear Admiral of check and his
team were able to combine data streams
utilize supply chain visuals
visualization tools from DoD and input
data into the cloud this system is now
available to generate reports for
governor's showing what their state
received from the federal government and
commercial partners all the way down to
the hospital level as I noted and thanks
to President Trump and his
administration governor's now have
visibility as to where their supplies
are sent and where they're received and
from March 1st through May 10th this
public-private partnership has led to
the delivery these are extraordinary
numbers of over 113 million in 95
respirator masks nearly half a billion
surgical masks nearly 18 million face
shields and over 12 billion gloves that
is a lot of PPE and we thank our private
sector partners for engaging in this
effort with us
also I just wanted to note that earlier
today the president held an hour-long
call with thousands of Hispanic
community business and faith leaders
across the country he recognized the
many contributions of the Hispanic
community to our country and addressed
important issues like how to reopen
their businesses and build the greatest
economy in history again
and finally before I take questions I
just wanted to note on a separate note
that I wanted to acknowledge the passing
of Ravi Zacharias a renowned Christian
apologist who left this world yesterday
our prayers are with Robbie's family
during this time he meant a lot to a lot
of people around this administration and
as my father said Billy Graham was the
great evangelist and Ravi Zacharias was
the great apologist and we are all
thinking about him and holding him close
to our hearts and his family today and
with that I'll take questions John
Bailey what does the president believe
is illegal about the secretary of state
of Michigan setting of absentee ballot
application saying what federal funding
is he considering withholding from the
state of Michigan as a result so you
know I won't get into exactly what the
funding considerations are I would note
that his tweets were meant to alert
secretary minuchin and mr. Vogt about
some ahead of OMB about his concerns
with trillions of dollars going to these
states and his noted concerns about a
lot of fraud that is potentially at play
when you have mass mail and voting so
with regard to the illegality and
legality of it that's a question for the
campaign as to their voting and ballot
practices but I would just note that his
tweet was meant to alert OMB he wanted
to be very careful as we send trillions
of dollars to states that we keep this
important point in mine and we ensure
that there's fairness in our voting
system and absolute accuracy but the
President himself has voted just two
months ago vial of Mahlon
there are several Republican states
they're also doing these mail and
applications for ballots and so I'm
confused what is it that he thinks is
illegal that's happening in Michigan he
doesn't really specify so first with
regard to the president doing a mail and
vote the president is after all the
president which means he's here in
Washington he's unable to cast his vote
down in Florida his state of residence
so for him that's why he had to do a
mail and vote but he supports mail and
voting for a reason when you have a
reason that you are unable to be present
there's right now we're very far from
November 3rd I would I'm glad that you
have the prediction tool and you can
tell us what will be happening on
November 3rd 2020 I certainly don't know
it as the present Aires coming up and
that's like what's happening in two
violen what I would also I assume you
care about fairness and accuracy in our
elections do you not you can go look
this up on ProPublica there is a
bipartisan consensus on the fact that
mass mail-in voting can lead to fraud
there was a 2005 commission by none
other than President Carter who's not a
member of the Republican Party and also
James Baker about this concluding that
these ballots quote remain the largest
source of potential voter fraud so this
is a concern the president's right to
look at this we want a free and fair
election and that's his concern yes II
can everyone the president deleted his
first tweet which alleged volta that
they see a vision of Kenny
absolutely balanced every butter in fact
they stepped out absolutely palette
requests was the president misinformed
this morning
and why I feel only directing this
message to Michigan not other states
Georgia others that are sending similar
absentee ballot requests to their sales
so the president corrected his tweet as
you noted and with regard to going state
by states and looking at ballots and the
way they're distributed that would be a
question for the Trump campaign and I'd
refer you to the campaign on that point
the g7 any more details over the time
when the president would like for that
to schedule a few are Washington and
does that mean that travel restrictions
that are currently in place on time
travel from uh from Europe to China in
other places would potentially be
relaxed before that meeting would take
place here so I won't get into the
mechanics of how that would happen I
would know that the president really
wants to see the g7 happen here in
Washington as we be again not just to
reopen the country but as the world
begins to reopen you'd like to see it
happen sometime in June but as to a
particular date I don't have any
announcement on that front or to the
mechanisms of how we'd make that work a
couple of questions for you one this
president Trump to support the CDC
guidelines that were released over the
weekend and if so why were they released
so quietly why not talk about them roll
them out here from the podium so the CDC
guidelines there was a 60 page document
that came out last night that I assume
you're referencing on that document I
talked I talked to dr. Redfield earlier
today about it and much of that was
already out there so appendices ABC MD
had been out there for a while appendix
e he said he thinks got posted sometime
late last week and again these were his
rough estimates he was giving me
appendix F was being discussed and there
was constructive criticism of it through
the task force and the interagency
process so that was refined and my point
in sharing that with you is that the 60
page document was merely an aggregation
of a lot of what was already out there
so it's not as if this was new
information that we were announcing but
it was more guidance pursuant to our
reopening of America guidance that was
issued several weeks ago husbands
work the guidelines did you think
Americans should follow those guidelines
or should they be following the initial
guidelines so the president's been very
clear he supports the reopening of
America guidelines the CDC guidelines
are in concert with those guidelines he
wants to safely reopen this country it's
very important we do so and it's good to
see that most states I think basically
all of them have plans at this point to
reopen and we're starting to see the
safe reopening of several states and
Americans getting back to work
we should get your reaction to something
huge got a moments ago a statement from
the American Nurses Association which
says quote the American Nurses
Association has not received reports
from nurses or other frontline health
care workers utilizing
hydroxychloroquine as a preventive
treatment for kovat 19:00 why does the
president continue to say that many or
thousands of frontline workers are using
it as a prophylactic well there is I'm
at Henry Ford Hospital is doing a study
on this now where 3,000 frontline
workers will be taking
hydroxychloroquine to look at X use as a
prophylaxis I believe there's a few
hundred or a hundred 90 workers and
Tampa General Hospital's so this is
being used by by some and one thing I
want to note with regard to
hydroxychloroquine because I think it's
very important that were as accurate as
we can be with our reporting on this
hydroxychloroquine has been a drug that
has been in use for 65 years for lupus
arthritis and malaria it has a very good
safety profile but it as with any drug
and as with any prescription it should
be given by a doctor to a patient in
that context so no one should be taking
this without a prescription from their
doctor but that being said I've seen a
lot of apoplectic coverage of
hydroxychloroquine you know Jimmy Kimmel
saying the president's quote trying to
kill himself by taking it you had Joe
Scarborough saying quote this will kill
you Neil Cavuto saying what have you got
to lose them one thing you have to lose
our lives and you had Chris Cuomo saying
the president knows that
hydroxychloroquine is not supported by
science he knows it has been flying
flagged by his own people and he's using
it well Cuomo mocked the president for
this and interestingly I found this out
just before coming here
hydroxychloroquine of course is an
fda-approved medication with a long
proven track record for safety and it
turns out that Chris Cuomo took a less
safe version of it called quinine which
the FDA removed from the market in 2006
because of its serious side effects
including death so really interesting to
have that criticism of the President on
that note - Chris Cuomo I'd like to
redirect him to his brother the governor
of New York Governor Cuomo who has
several on-the-record statements about
hydroxychloroquine saying I'm an
optimist I'm hopeful about the drug and
that's why I will try it here in New
York as soon as we get it
there has been anecdotal evidence that
it's promising that's why we're going
ahead and I have about eight other
quotes from Governor Cuomo should any of
you have interest in that you saw those
studies though there are trials that are
in their early phases do you any
evidence that thousands of frontline
workers are currently using it because
they believe it actually will prevent
them from getting the FDA has approved
this for off-label use you know this
president's a big believer and right to
try legislation people who are in their
last work there are several studies that
have been broad that the president has
actually mentioned that I'd refer you to
there was one out of France a French
study involving more than a thousand
patients that found that the vast
majority had quote good clinical
outcomes and by the vast majority that
was more than 90% there was an Italian
study of more than 65,000 patients that
demonstrated only 20 tested positive of
those who were taking it
prophylactically in a South Korea study
as well so there are several studies and
if you're someone out there and this is
a safe drug to use and your doctor
importantly to underscore that and your
doctor prescribes it for your use as a
prophylaxis or after coming into contact
with Cova then it's something you should
take if it's prescribed by the doctor
and that's your personal medical choice
yes governor the stance is just
that the president may be going down to
Florida for the SpaceX NASA launch next
week is that accurate so we have no news
on scheduling at that front but if I if
I get news in the future I will
certainly provide that for you yes Jeff
Kaylee how often does the president talk
to director vote or acting director vote
from the audience - who - the acting
director of OMB often an ie just was in
the Oval Office with the president so
they do speak often I don't have a
readout of the president's schedule but
they do speak regularly he wanted to
flag to him his concerns about Michigan
why don't he just tell him instead of
sending a tweet because the President
believes an unprecedented transparency
and I'm sure you as a journalist Tom are
very eager and excited when you learn
about the president's decision-making
process in real time whether that's on
Twitter for me here up at the podiums
you just said that way that was the
reasoning for him but I'm saying this is
a transparent president and I think that
that's something that you should be
allotting rather than question as to why
he decided to tweet this do you have any
other answers from g7 leaders that they
they are willing definitely willing to
come here so we will get into the
president's private conversations and
correspondences on with world leaders
but we do hope to see this happen we
hope that how can you characterize the
response as being great how's a good
idea or thinking about it so I don't
have any information about the response
from world leaders but we certainly hope
to see this happen yes yes thank you
could you clarify please president
Trump's comments about saying that it
was a good idea it was good that there
were so many positive tests for for a
cope at 19 whereas a lot of people look
at that and say that this was actually a
terrible that we have actually
third of all the cases in the world well
look I would note this that the
president what he was saying there is
that we are testing when you have more
cases in order to identify those cases
you have to have tested a high volume of
people so the more you test the more
cases numerically not necessarily as a
percent positive but numerically you
will see just by volume sheer volume of
your testing and the president's done an
extraordinary job on this front
Washington Post surveyed governor's
offices and state health department's
and found out at least a dozen states
have testing capacity that outstrips the
supply of patients that's a very good
job done by our federal government and
supporting the states to cite the
governor of New York again quote we have
more sites and more testing capacity
than we're using so we're testing a lot
and thus we're finding a number of cases
but as we safely reopen we do have some
encouraging numbers on that front that
we continue to see a week over week
decline a fifteen percent decline in
deaths in just the last week April 1st
to mid-may 50 percent decline a new
hospitalization and under 25,000 cases
today so we are seeing progress can you
tell us what law specifically the
president thinks the Secretary of State
in Michigan broke by sending out the
applications and did the Secretary of
State in Georgia also break that law by
sending out
patience for thier fire again I direct I
reference you to the campaign these are
ballot questions I reference you to the
campaign is the President and we are
your mower my sermon employers the White
House so yeah but that's not a campaign
question that's the president the United
States saying that initiatives that you
have in absentee ballots so I would
refer you to the campaign on that front
and I would note to you that many of
those ballots that are submitted via
mail can be fraudulent I cited to the
bipartisan study I can read it again
maybe you weren't paying attention when
I read it the first time so read it
again President Carter a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots remained the largest
source of potential voter fraud so if
you cast a ballot via mail and you do so
fraudulently that would be an illegal
act and I'd point you to that and for
further I'd point you to my former
employer which is the Trump campaign yes
thank you Kelly on two questions if I
may firstly on airports the TSA is
reportedly considering setting up
temperature checks at airports
given the numbers of people who can be
asymptomatic or sick without a fever
do you think that's sufficient and why
was it more done to have screening at
airports sooner particularly in light of
the House Oversight investigation that
called screening from international hot
spots and March limited stagnant so the
president is working with TSA he's
working with Airlines we want to ensure
that our TSA employees are safe that
those who are traveling are safe and he
has had those conversations and we are
keeping people safe at the TSA and the
passengers as well heard over 500 TSA
employees that become sick and six are
dead so again you know do you think this
has been enough action and soon enough
we've taken action we're working with
the TSA we're keeping on America's
essential workers safe and we are
praying for all of those who have been
affected by Corona Vaughn another
program
ask about the president's son and
business partner Eric Trump he recently
said a firown' virus that quote the
Democrats are trying to milk this and
predicted it will quote magically all of
a sudden go away and disappear and
everyone will be able to reopen after
the election in November do you think
herb Trump's comments are accurate and
also appropriate I think we all hope
coronavirus goes away and I think we as
we continue to take the president his
family out of context um we should
endeavor to quote them accuracy and I
think we should all hope that the
coronavirus goes was not sure we should
all look that the coronavirus goes away
yes
is there a timeline for when a UK and
European Union citizens and visitors are
allowed to come back into the United
States and will all European countries
be included or could it be a
case-by-case basis so we don't have a
timeline on that just yet I can tell you
the president's preeminent concern is
keeping Americans safe his travel
restrictions have saved lives as dr.
Falchi and others have noted so we don't
have an announcement one will be rolling
those back but his priority his number
one concern is America first and held
them well-being of the nation first yes
thanks Haley the associate for governor
Whitmer said that she's been planning to
meet
patient Amaro's wonder if there's a
reason why the governor Whitner with
merced or in in michigan wasn't extended
in an invitation to the president's
appearance in michigan tomorrow tomorrow
and I was wondering if there's a reason
why he wasn't gonna meet with her like
other guys I don't think there was a
particular reason I it didn't come up
but you know while I on that note I
would point to governor Whitmer it
sounds like she's curious about an
invitation but she should be quite happy
that thanks to this federal government
FEMA obligated more than two hundred
sixteen point two million dollars to
Michigan eight point six million n95
respirator 740,000 eighteen surgical
masks three hundred eleven thousand five
hundred seventy-one face shields I
should round these up or we'll be here
all day seven hundred sixty thousand
gloves seven hundred ventilators the
president has done quite a bit for
Michigan and her concerns and invitation
but she should be thanking the president
for all the supplies that he's delivered
to her State yes yes clearly the
president has made clear that he's
concerned about liability issues as
companies reopen now it is the White
House engaged with Republican senators
about this issue and would the president
sign another bill another Kovach bill
without liability being addressed in
that so I won't lay out the president's
conditions or lack thereof for any
upcoming legislation he has mentioned it
that it's something that needs to be
looked at closely and he is looking at
closely and he is discussing with
members of the hill about that but he
has made clear in terms of the phase
four that he wants to be slow as we
approach phase four and not rush forward
with spending trillions more dollars of
taxpayer money leave we've done a lot so
far and he'll look at doing more in the
future and liabilities definitely
something that he's concerned about him
working on right back there oh one more
on g7
you you think that would be appropriate
to hold a g7 summit in the US while
ordinary citizens are still not allowed
to travel freely for example from Europe
ya mean the president wants us to start
reopening travel restrictions are
something that you know he wants to make
sure American lives are protected before
those are lifted but that being said I
do think it's entirely appropriate so
does the president have a g7 here
America's reopening the world's
reopening I mean what a show of strength
and optimism to have all of the leaders
of these countries come together at the
White House and pursue business as usual
and as we move forward through this
pandemic is there anyone I haven't
gotten to just I guess not
okay so we'll do it we'll do a few more
yeah I had a brief answer Susan Rice
rode out there yesterday at the New York
Times it said that President Trump is
counsel to the president G and also has
said that called his response to the
coronavirus deadly classified as a
deadly mishandling what's the White
House's response to it um so you said
that that came from Susan Rice was it
okay so first I would want to take a
moment to address the president's
response because the president has had
an extraordinary an early response to
the corona virus I would know dr. Burks
the early work of President Trump both
with travel restrictions and quarantine
has bought us the time and space
necessary to have this task force be
very effective dr. Feld she's saying
that the president's response has been
impressive he can't imagine under any
circumstance that anyone could be doing
anything more I can go through the
actions there's a detailed timeline out
there of January 6th wuhan issuing a
travel travel notice issued on wuhan
when there were zero cases in the United
States the seventeenth zero reported us
cases and there were Public Health entry
screenings at major US airports of
course the infamous travel restrictions
that were called xenophobic by Democrats
on January 31st a lot of action in
February on developing a test on and
making sure we were moving forward as
speedily as possible on that keep in
mind in late February Pelosi was saying
come to Chinatown it's
very safe but the president had already
taken very early action and I know he
brought up Susan Rice in that context
but I'm going to bring her up in another
context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified from Susan Rice on
Inauguration Day which is so peculiar
set the scene it's an ovulation day
you're moving out of the White House
this is the most powerful building on
planet earth Susan Rice is moving out to
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing her boxes
she's not being nostalgic about her time
in the White House what she's doing is
writing an email where three times she
writes that President Obama emphasized
to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn by the book by the book by
the book she writes that three times as
a Shakespeare said thou doth protest too
much Susan Rice he didn't have the Susan
Rice part in there but I'll add that in
to she was asked specifically about the
unmasking and Michael Flynn asked her
after she discussed it on January 5th in
the Oval Office with Obama after she
wrote this email to herself on
inauguration day she was asked by a good
journalist Judy Woodruff about this
email and she said about the unmasking
of Michael Flynn not the email but the
unmasking she was asked specifically
about noonas his claims specifically so
let me clarify was known as his claim
and she said I know nothing about this
so it was a lie and then Susan Rice
since no one brought it up to me I will
bring it up to you her attorney said
that this was the first opportunity
three weeks after this oval office
meeting that she had to write this email
memorializing her Oval Office meeting
with a Barack Obama discussing Michael
Flynn it was her first opportunity she
said interesting because she had an
opportunity in those three weeks on
January 10th to do a passing of the
baton event with none other than Michael
Flynn where she praised him wished him
success and talked about the great
transition into the White House and then
on January 12th she was able to
participate in a story that published on
that date in the lifestyle section of
the Washington Post so she never had
time to write this email until
inauguration day as she's rushing out
the door when in fact she had an
opportunity to do all of those things
I'll leave that with you thank you for
bringing up Susan Rice not makaan
texts that I wished but for allowing me
to share that with you
you
you
you
you
one two